on accueille christiane lambert bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
christiane lambert êtes la présidente de
la fnsea c'est le premier syndicat
agricole est à mes côtés pour vous
interroger fabrice veysseyre redon du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france bonjour fabrice merci
d'être avec nous au coeur des
préoccupations de ce salon évidemment
christiane lambert et à cette guerre en
ukraine les combats continuent ce matin
avant de parler des conséquences pour
l'agriculture
vous avez lancé une campagne de dons
notamment une campagne dead pour les
ukrainiens le cren évidemment grands
pays agricoles comment concrètement et
se traduit cette campagne de dons
comment vous les aidez ces ukrainiens
alors en tant que présidente européenne
dès jeudi dernier à bruxelles j'étais à
côté de mes collègues de lituanie de
lettonie de pologne de roumanie qui sont
tout proches et qui sont inquiets eux
mêmes ont déjà engagé un certain nombre
de d'activité dedans et d'accueil aussi
j'ai donc proposé en france et beaucoup
d'agriculteurs y sont sensibles qu'on
puisse aussi voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire ici dans notre pays bien sûr il y
a des dons dont nous avons pris attache
avec l'ambassade d'ukraine en france
avec les associations croix rouge
internationale notamment et saturn
d'associations france ukraine pour voir
qu'est ce que de quoi ils ont besoin
l'idée majeure c'est de se référer à ce
que diront les autorités il ya une
cellule qui se met en place aujourd'hui
au quai d'orsay nous allons bien nous
avons proposé nos services pour
accueillir y compris les familles des
personnes qui pourraient en avoir besoin
la france est beaucoup plus loin que
d'autres pays dans l'intervalle entre
l'ukraine et la france mais nous sommes
à disposition et nous avons fait offre
de services pour ce qui est des donc
nous avons une association qui s'appelle
solal solidarité agricole
agroalimentaire qui sait collecter les
dons qui s'assurait la logistique et qui
pourra articulé avec le quai d'orsay
l'envoi vers les régions d'ukraine où il
y en aura besoin nous ne voulons pas
interférer négativement nous sommes à
disposition est vraiment comme nous
sommes nous mêmes dans l'organisation
nous savons toute la complexité donc
nous inscrirons dans le sillage de tout
ce qui existe pour l'instant nous
recensons les disponibilités et les
volontaires questions sur les
conséquences de cette crise pour les
agriculteurs parce que les conséquences
du durcissement des relations avec la
russie un train de mesures a été annoncé
un train de sanctions
vous craignez vous craignez des
conséquences pour le monde agricole et
pour des secteurs en particulier je
dirais qu'il y en a déjà puisque la nuit
de l'intervention de la russie en
ukraine et céréales le blé le maïs le
toto de tournesol tournesol ont flambé
il ya une nuance importante et donc cela
va se traduire directement par une
augmentation des coûts de l'alimentation
animale donc une augmentation des frais
pour les agriculteurs éleveurs par
exemple les producteurs de porcs qui
sont forts utilisateurs de céréales et
bien si le cours et la cotation mondiale
augmente ça risque d'impacter plus leurs
coûts de production
c'est un risque aussi par rapport aux
engrais déjà l'année dernière les
engrais azotés sur la seule année 2000
21 avait augmenté de 138% les engrais
azotés c'est dire si nous craignons
effectivement que la russie est un grand
pays producteur de gaz indépendant du
gaz russe à ce 17 % du pétrole russe à
23% donc cette souveraineté énergétique
cadeau qu'on a construit vladimir
poutine lui donne aujourd'hui une
autorité et un pouvoir en quelque sorte
donc ça nous inquiète
oui parce que la dernière fois que il ya
une invasion de la crimée et des
décisions européennes
et bien c'est l'agriculture qui a
trinqué en quelque sorte milliards de
pertes pour la ferme france et il n'a
jamais réouvert nous exportions 75 mille
tonnes de porc français 750 mille tonnes
de porc européens plus haut qu'une tonne
aujourd'hui et la russie a construit un
élevage porcin performant et exporte
elle même aujourd'hui enfermez vous
dites sur le plan de la souveraineté
alimentaire vladimir poutine un pouvoir
que nous français que non européens
n'avons pas oui parce que vladimir
poutine a construit une souveraineté
alimentaire à grand renfort de quaero
avec notamment la vente du gaz et
gazprom et ses entreprises il a
construit sa force alimentaires là où
l'europe la france a laissé filer sur
d'agriculture nous nous importons
beaucoup plus de produits venant d'
union européenne aujourd'hui qu'il ya
une dizaine d'années
la france n'a pas mesuré l'importance de
la souveraineté alimentaire l'europe non
plus l'europe est en train de réfléchir
à une stratégie dans le green deal qui
s'appelle farm to fork de la ferme à la
fourchette et qui risque de se traduire
par une perte de production de 12 à 17%
20% dans la production de pommes et de
betteraves par exemple donc au nom de
l'environnement par dessus tout c'est un
abandon une production dont kiel quand
vous dites la france ça veut dire qu'il
ya des erreurs politiques qui ont été
faites il ya eu des erreurs politiques
la part de qui dans ce quinquennat
de différents gouvernements qui ont
voulu laver plus vert que vert qui ont
introduit qui ont interdit les produits
phytosanitaires alors qu'ils sont
autorisées ailleurs qui est interdit par
exemple de produire des légumes bio sous
serre alors qu'eux ils viennent
aujourd'hui d'autres pays qui les
cultivent sous serre la france est la
championne de la sur une transposition
et des normes xxl donc je pense qu'on a
voulu faire pour l'écologie ça pénalise
aujourd'hui notre souverain alimentaire
oui ça a pénalisé alors qu'il est
possible nous le pensons de concilier et
l'écologie et la souveraineté
alimentaire ça s'appelle la croissance
durable c'est que ce que font beaucoup
de pays elle avec plus de pragmatisme
que d'idéologie et en écoutant plus et
scientifique que les idéologues sauf que
là nous apporte qui les idées
aujourd'hui sauf que la part dont nous
importons 40% de nos poulets nous
important 60 % de nos fruits on dit aux
français manger cinq fruits et légumes
par jour et on importe 60% en afrique en
s'imposant nos légumes ce que vous
n'êtes pas sérieux christiane lambert ce
que nous importons la ccif que vous
donnez est ce qu'on est capable
aujourd'hui en france de les produire on
est capable de reconquérir et c'est une
des stratégies que développe la
fédération nationale des producteurs de
légumes passé de 45 % d'importation de
légumes à 35% sous cinq ans c'est-à-dire
reconquérir de la production de légumes
en france et de la production de fruits
en france quand j'ai dut payant des
jeunes agriculteurs il ya 25 ans nous
produisions 400 mille tonnes de pêches
et de nectarines dans la vallée du rhône
notamment l'ardèche la drôme aujourd'hui
nous n'en produisons plus que 200 mille
tonnes la france en consomme toujours
400 mille tonnes mais nous importons 200
mille tonnes de pays qui ont des coûts
de production inférieurs
moralité ça tire les prix vers le bas
donc il ya eu de la délocalisation de
production tout comme il y a eu de la
désindustrialisation
interview juste sur cette guerre en
ukraine christiane lambert le chef de
l'état était là samedi matin il vous a
promis un plan de résilience on imagine
que vous travaillez dessus avec julien
de normandie on en est aujourd'hui de ce
plan de résilience qu'est ce qui va être
fait concrètement pour nos agriculteurs
il faut d'abord appréhender quelles
sanctions vont être prises sur quels
produits calibrés les pertes que nous
allons subir c'est ce qui est en train
d'être fait et les premières réunions
vont avoir lieu en ce début de semaine
le ministre l'agriculture qui préside
l'union européenne france qui préside
l'union européenne réunis demain
l'ensemble des mises de l'agriculture
européens parce que les sanctions seront
prises contre les européens quel pays
cibles eux ont-ils nous n'en savons rien
donc faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui il ya
plus d'importation de lait fromages
beurres poissons etc par contre il
continue à importer du vin des alcools
des aliments infantiles des pet food des
préparations culinaires sauf ici qu'est
ce qui doit y avoir dans ce plan de
résilience pour vous qu'est ce que vous
vous demandez ce matin tout ça sans ce
qu'il faut c'est compensé les pertes que
nous subirons liés à ces décisions
unilatérales de la russie la dernière
fois pour la l'ukraine pour la crimée en
2014 c'est un milliard de pertes nous
allons chiffrer la perte et nous
demanderons les compensations pour
l'instant les ceux qui souffrent le plus
ce qu'achète de l'aliment pour le bétail
donc les producteurs de porcs les
producteurs de veaux les producteurs
laitiers les producteurs de lapins tous
les animals in votre interlocuteur là
pour ces compensations c'est la france
ou l'europe c'est la france qui préside
l'union européenne et donc il faut que
la commission européenne aussi se
mobilise nous avons vu que la communauté
internationale se mobilise pour aider
les ukrainiens et c'est nécessaire il
faut que madame ursula von der leyen qui
préside la commission européenne est à
l'esprit que les décisions de sanction
contre la russie occasionneront une
riposte de la russie et que les secteurs
économiques victimes devront être
accompagnés pour tenir un mot puisque
l'actualité c'est aussi la fin des
négociations ces prochaines heures entre
les agriculteurs et la grande
distribution elles sont compliquées ces
négociations par la guerre en ukraine
est ce qu'elles vont aboutir elles sont
pas compliquées par la guerre du crâne
elles sont compliquées par
l'irresponsabilité des distributeurs
c'est tout les distributeurs n'ont pas
entendu la crise en ukraine pour
remettre la pression sur les industriels
qu'est ce qui se passe nous avons cette
loi qui arrive au 1er janvier 2023 avec
des nouvelles règles non négociabilité
des prix payés aux agriculteurs quand le
lait a été payé 400 euros tonne le
distributeur peut pas dire vous baisser
un peu sur les producteurs de lait parce
que moi je veux pas vendre plus cher ils
ont plus le droit et dans ce sens pas
une bonne nouvelle ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle aboutir christensen c'est une
bonne nouvelle mais écoutez madame
aboutir si elles aboutissent à la baisse
c'est pas un bon aboutissement de toutes
façons et elle se termine ce soir donc
il faut que ce soir et distributeurs
irresponsable parce qu'il y en a ceux
qui n'ont pas accepté des hausses alors
que les coûts de production augmentent
de 8% c'est historique de 15 16% dont
certains produits on n'est pas sûr 2%
dont ont besoin les industriels quand
une entreprise à une augmentation de 2%
elle gère elle supprime un certain
nombre de postes de charges quand ces 8
% soit c'est du licenciement salariés
parce que c'est le seul levier qu'il le
reste soit c'est le dépôt de bilan merci
christiane lambert merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
[Musique]